Slow
[Silence]
down. Hello.
Alhamdulillah. Continuing
the chapters regarding the etiquates of
relieving oneself.
Continuing where we left off yesterday
morning,
which is that the author tells us that
it is permissible
for a person to clean himself
after
using the restroom, after relieving
oneself
using water or using stones or using
anything
of
similar properties, Right?
Meaning
if we boil it down, anything that is wet
that cleans or anything that is dry that
cleans, right?
And the author mentions
narrations
that bolster
this statement. And that is that often
times we have narrations where the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam would go to
relieve himself and he would have his
servants carry water for him if it was
available.
But often times, especially if they were
traveling, he would use or tell them to
gather for him
something that is dry stones or the
likes.
Heat. Heat.
We have
narrates that the messenger of Allah
said, "If any of you goes to relieve
himself, then he is to take with him
three stones and purify and wipe himself
with said stones, for they will suffice
Now the next thing that the author tells
us is that it is not permissible to use
any less than three.
It is not permissible to use less than
three. And
it is permissible to use as many as
necessary but no less than three.
Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
I understand.
He narrates to us that
it's it's mentioned that someone said
in other words of this narration it was
a Jewish man who said to him your
prophet has taugh taught you all
everything
to the finest details of your lives
even how to relieve yourselves and he
said that is and some man responded
correct
He prohibited us from facing or turning
our backs to the
when we are urinating or defecating.
And he taught us that and he prohibited
us from using our right hands when
wiping or cleaning ourselves.
And he further prohibited us from
wiping ourselves with any less than
three
stones or rocks.
And he prohibited us as well from using
manure, dried manure, dried
droppings, right?
or bones to clean ourselves. So,
especially camels, especially camels,
but other animals as well, such as
you know, cows or
bulls or horses, right? Or even
mules, donkeys. They have a rather large
droppings, right?
And it hardens
and when it gets hard, person could pick
it up and presumably use it to wipe
himself. But the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam prohibited using
the droppings of animals even if those
droppings are pure in themselves. Horse
droppings are pure, right? They're not
nudges. Camel droppings are not nudges.
He prohibited from using those
droppings, those dried droppings to wipe
ourselves
and also bones. You know, you're out in
the desert, especially on a beaten path,
a path well taken, well treaded.
the paths in and out of cities
and so forth, you're going to find lots
of droppings. You're going to find lots
of animal bones
either from people eating or from
animals dying and and you know becoming
bones. And so these things are
prohibited to use for
cleaning oneself
after
using the restroom after relieving
yourself. Why is that? Well, in this
narration, it's not mentioned.
But in Muslim, the prophet
teaches us
He teaches us that this dried manure and
these bones they are
used as food by
your
counterparts from amongst the jin and
their animals, the jin's animals.
So the jin somehow
eat and feed their animals bones
and
animal droppings. So the animals are
eating the animal droppings and the gin
themselves are eating
or nourishing themselves from the bones.
In another
narration also in Muslim, the prophet
tells us that he made permissible for
the jin.
He made permissible for the jin to eat
and nourish themselves with any bone of
any of any animal whom Allah's name was
mentioned upon upon slaughtering. So
just we have this for our meat, the
Muslim from amongst the jin have this
rule for the bones.
Now a person may say well how does that
work? Hello.
I I don't know how this works. I would
have to have lived with the gym and
observe their eating habits in order to
know how this works.
Do they deplete these bones in some
you know in some u quantifiable way?
The jin themselves are hidden from us.
how much more so the way that they eat
or the way that they, you know, what
kind of animals they use. Also, we see
in this narration that the jin have some
kind of animals that are also hidden
from us that we don't see. And so there
is an entire dimension
of Jin and entire civilizations of Jin
existing
right next to us in the same places in
the same times. Yet we can't see them.
They can see us. This is how Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala made us. The human
being is primary in this junction or
in this leg of the world's history.
Before the creation of Adam, the jin
were primary. They were the only
intelligent
you know free world creatures living
on the earth
and residing here. However, they
failed. They failed very
seriously to the point that they were
all but eradicated and made as
secondary to the existence of
humanity here on this earth. It's the
human beings era. It's the epic of
humanity at this point. So while they do
live here, they live in a dimension in a
way that they are veiled from us. we
cannot see them. furthermore, if we
knew
if we knew
and I had some kind of knowledge of how
the jin eat bones and how they what kind
of animals they ride and so forth, would
this in any way enhance our relationship
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala? this
kind of knowledge, knowledge of the
exact
comingings and goings of the lifestyle
of the gin. Of course not. This is
something that is largely
unnecessary for us to know what we need
to know about the jin that affects our
existence or affects our relationship
with Allah. we've been told of. Other
than that, it is not something to dwell
upon.
However, if you wanted to read a book on
this topic, the scholars have
compiled
books specifically on
all matters having to do with the jin.
And a contemporary book that was praised
by the scholars of Islam is a book
written by
was a Jordanian scholar in the ' 70s
' 80s and '9s and he wrote a few books
on the topic.
I don't know Muhammad.